hello everyone welcome to the stream
um first before we get into you know how
i'm doing day five of quarantine
i'm totally fine for the record i'm okay
i did want to let you all know if you
didn't already know
that my youtubes came out today
this little lady um
you can grab one right now the link is
in the description
there are limited editions so when they
sell out they're completely gone but i
think we've made it i'm not positive
about this
but we should have made it so that it
doesn't sell out too quickly
um just the way that they allocate based
on that stuff but
yeah it's basically i think it's the
coolest thing in the world i'm giving
this one
specifically to my grandma even though i
think it might technically be a
prototype
um but yes people keep asking about the
controller
who's not an xbox controller uh nor is
it a playstation controller nor is it
a stadia controller which is the one i
think it looks most like it's just a
generic controller
just the one that is the most common
shape uh we got my little coffee cup
here
got my jordans on the bottom i think
it's really cool of course because
of you know me as a human proceeds
proceeds will go to charity
um but i don't think we'll know exactly
what that looks like until september
when it actually comes out but you can
pre-order it right now
and yeah when it's gone it is gone so
you gotta jump on one
now the music is too loud okay let me
turn it down
my voice should be pretty loud it looks
like i'm peeking
um so
the music is a little bit quieter maybe
it's too quiet i don't know
it'll be fine
um in any case yeah i
am currently on day
five of my mandatory uh
isolation um and yeah people had a lot
of questions i had a lot of australians
reach out after my first video so i
thought i would just stream for a bit to
kind of talk about it but
i'm doing totally fine i'm not bored at
all supposedly that's people's most
common problem but i brought so much
technology with me
i have two laptops an extra screen for
one of my laptops nintendo switch an
xbox series s
um and this laptop is a gaming laptop
this is a razer
uh it's wonderful um i'm good
i am not bored at all i'm still working
on american hours of course so i've been
generally actually waking up at five
and then i go to uh or i finish work
because
most of my colleagues have finished work
now i'm actually kind of breaking up my
day and giving myself a big chunk of
time in the middle
um because it's 11 30 a.m in australia
right now but 6 30
p.m in california which is where my
office is so those are our office hours
uh i've been giving myself like a four
hour break in the middle
so i work in the morning and then they
all leave and then i kind of do more
work at night um
because the flexible workout was like
obviously for meetings i have to be
there for the meetings but for
any of the writing that i have to do i
just kind of do later and it's been
really nice for me
i'm really enjoying it um
but yes it is it's okay
really the biggest issue that i'm having
is that i'm having trouble breathing
which is an issue um i did get my covert
test on the second
day that is um and they said that if we
had covert they would reach out to us
after two days so i do not have covet
but i'm having trouble breathing
because uh i have pretty serious asthma
i did warn them before we even got in
here i was like is there any chance of a
balcony because i am an asthmatic and
this is going to be tough for me
but there's no balcony uh there is a
giant window but it cannot be opened so
there's no fresh air
so um pretty much every day all day i
have asthma which
is a pretty big problem i would say
but there's nothing i can do about that
um
i got some zyrtec delivered which is an
allergy med that might help me because a
lot of the times it comes from
dust um but otherwise
not a ton i can do about not being able
to breathe um that's really the worst
part
and also a human
being in a hotel room turns out it gets
dirty pretty quickly
just like you know splashes of water in
the bathroom or like
i ate some popcorn and now there's bits
of popcorn on the floor
and you can't clean the room no one's
allowed in here
they're not gonna give me a vacuum so
that's the only thing that i had not
thought about that is pretty weird
um but otherwise it's doing okay uh yes
of course i know caffeine is good for
asthma
you're not allowed to have humidifiers
or nebulizers oh sorry you can't have a
nebulizer but you can't have a
humidifier
um you're not allowed any of that stuff
so there's nothing i can do
um
uh you i don't think these windows can
open which is why i can't
open them they literally cannot open so
it's not even an option
um you can't vacuum your own room
because you don't have vacuums
no chem they do not let you outside at
all i am
locked in this room the whole time
but again i really am okay it's it's
pretty much fine for me
um it's yeah just the breathing thing is
is a major problem so i wanted to talk
about the food
stuff because now i have some food on
hand today
this is uh kind of the way you get the
food just in
a little i actually got they sent me two
boxes for whatever reason this time
naturally this is what i ate it was
pasta with some meatballs it was really
nice
and then i have this as well um
that all comes in just a brown bag that
they drop outside the door
three times a day mine i adjusted the
time so now i'm getting
i get lunch at 11am dinner at 3 p.m
and breakfast at 5am um so they knock on
the door pretty loudly
and then leave something out there for
you uh you have to wait 30 seconds put a
mask on grab the bag close the door
that's the most
outside time that i get it's very
exciting um
but the food's really good i'm enjoying
it i'm totally cool
and i had family members send me snacks
a friend sent me a bunch of snacks
yesterday
um so i've got those too got lots of
fruit
uh what about getting rid of trash in
bags you just uh
put the trash back out the frontal
food comes from the kitchen at this
hotel here
thermal shoes yes i am a game writer but
to be clear this is intended to be a q a
about the quarantine experience
not a general q a trying to uh help
anyone who's going to go through this
really because a lot of australians did
reach out to me and also because i know
it's an interesting circumstance
that people have questions not that
other people haven't gone through it of
course
do you get to choose the nutritional
value of these items no
you do get to choose between uh
different meal options and when you
checked in you're allowed to tell them
about any dietary restrictions so like
i imagine vegetarians or vegans are
allowed to
give notes about that but
um i don't know if there are cameras in
the hallway not sure
yes there will be more resident evil
gameplay this weekend i have already
recorded two more
just haven't posted them yet because i
try to space them apart probably post
the next one tomorrow which
doing my youtube upload schedule is
confusing me because
i'm still trying to upload on american
time
but it's one australian time so
i don't know we'll figure it out
uh how was the vaccine experience it's
totally fine
um if you want a snack do you call room
service yeah they deliver me
one coffee um a day at seven a.m which
is a cappuccino and then i will
generally order a second cappuccino
around this time um they also i think i
mentioned this but you get phone calls
every day
someone from reception will call they
called me today and i was like hey i
ordered the zyrtec has it arrived yet
just so that i can manage my breathing a
little bit better because
yeah that really is the hard part for me
i really am in a great position
the internet's strong enough for me to
stream i'm still working my job which is
like very distracting i'm effectively
just putting in more work than i need to
right now
um to fill the time um but otherwise i
have video games so
i'm really okay this isn't bothering me
at all i'm a very anti-social
um introverted person anyway so not
seeing
humans not a problem for me i think i've
lived alone for the last four years you
know like
i'm totally fine it's just the breathing
which um
again i didn't know coming into this
situation it was probably going to cause
me problems because my lungs do not like
hotel rooms
so hopefully getting antihistamines will
help a little bit but otherwise it's
just like i'm still using the medication
i have for asthma
um and i'm fine right now because i just
took it before i started streaming but
it only lasts like
30 minutes maybe and then i just kind of
close up again
do i have a basic coffee machine in the
room
no um i do have
a um
uh a kettle but i've actually ran out of
cups for tea
because they were recyclable um rahul
coley asks does
the hotel have adult channels on the tv
um i've actually not checked
yeah i'm not sure that's um
that's a good point i should look into
that uh
but also guy at reception
knew who i was so
and he was really lovely very very very
kind super accommodating like called me
and was like
hey i know you're working on us time
like he was the one who was like i saw
this you're working on us time what time
do you want meals he was super nice
but i kind of don't know that i want
that guy to know
um my taste in adult channels so
probably not going to do that
i have not had a sausage roll yet sandy
also hi nice to see you hi sarah nice to
see you too
um no i did ask a friend if they could
bring me one
but i don't know that they come to your
room that quickly i think i might try to
get someone to deliver me a social draw
but it might also be worth waiting until
i'm out
to have that first sausage roll
experience i don't know i'm
caught up on that i'm not sure what to
do
we'll see um
how much is the state considering it's
mandatory it's a good question
um and i don't actually know for sure
um which is a very weird part of this
cause i didn't get to pick the hotel
um it is very nice in my opinion like
i'm happy to be here i have the space
that i need i mean it's small
but i'm used to a small space because my
studio apartment i really feel like i'm
very well equipped to
deal with this kind of thing i'm again
aside from the breathing
completely fine um it is only day five
though
i'll be fine uh so yeah i
you don't get to choose a hotel or any
of that kind of thing so
they also don't tell you how much it's
gonna cost because you don't have a
choice
um i was told two thousand to two
thousand five hundred
so somewhere in that range
i have also ordered wine which added 15
and i think i'm having to pay for my
coffees i'm not even sure
so that adds to it too um but yeah it's
not cheap that's probably the most
prohibitive part i think that actually
australian citizens getting home
is not tremendously difficult the cost
is
prohibitive it is absurdly expensive the
whole whole step of the way so i knew
that
when i was planning to come home you
know from december
that i'd be coming home at this time of
year because it's my sister's due date
uh everyone congratulate my sister on
being extremely pregnant in chat please
so i basically just planned for that
like i knew it would cost me a [ __ ] ton
of money
um which is yeah the difficult part
about getting home though i do believe
that they have payment plans
uh if you
can't afford it and you can prove that
then you can pay it back slowly
i think it's how they do that um but
obviously it's 100 required there's no
way around it
uh that is in dollar dues correct that
would be australian dollars yeah
so um
that's about 1 500 if it's 2000 i think
um baron chan said have you been to new
zealand any plans to tour i have been to
new zealand
no plans to tour i really like it there
though but
it would be silly for me to go
to new zealand when all my family's in
australia i'm here to see my family it's
such a long flight
so thank you everyone for congratulating
my sister appreciate that she is
extremely pregnant
um
uh no red scorpion i do not have clovid
um i'm quarantined because it is a
requirement for coming back to australia
am i going to do another two week
quarantine when i come back to the u.s
it isn't part of the
legal requirements being in the u.s so
realistically
um again because i'm vaccinated you can
still get and spread covered that is
part of it it just wouldn't
be as bad for you probably what i'll do
when i get back
is take a covert test like immediately
and then wait for the results and then
just start seeing people again
um make sure i'm okay
have i been drinking more veggie juice
since i've been on lockdown
how would i do that i don't have access
to veggie juice
in lockdown i have whatever food they
give me which again is quite nice
um you keep asking me about halo
infinite sure i'll play it no i won't do
a playthrough
uh but again try and talk about
quarantine for this
the purposes of this particular q a uh
what am i playing in hotel quarantine
obviously i'm playing resident evil and
it is actually um
frustrating me a little bit because i
just i really like the game and i just
want to play through it but i keep
playing in hour chunks
so that i can then edit that hour so
that i can then publish that hour so i
have to keep stopping
uh because i don't necessarily have all
that much time to spare in any given day
because i'm still
working so having to stop has been
annoying me i'm like
[ __ ] i just want to finish this game
because i'm really enjoying it um like i
said i do have another two hours that
are good to go
but i keep recording it in separate
chunks basically so
playing resident evil still obviously in
small settings i've been playing mass
effect
um i restarted uh uh [ __ ] what's the
game called
forgotten the name of the game don't
remember
indie game very good completely blanking
on the name even though i was talking to
someone about it like an hour ago
that's my bad um i streamed a little bit
of the medium
sorry uh laser fear 2 not the medium i
will be playing the medium again in june
i have something lined up for that
also something very exciting that
happened just before the stream so that
you guys all know
um i interviewed lady dimitrisk
the actress who plays lady d so
i'm gonna um edit that video and then
send it off to her
to make sure she's cool with it not that
she asked for that i just always offered
to do that for interviews
and then um publish that on
the uh channel so that's a cool thing
that i got to do today
even though i'm here is it hard work to
edit videos while you also have a job
no i just work constantly so
um i assume you have no way of knowing
if you have a quarantine
neighbor in an adjoining room i mean
there are no adjoining rooms
but um i can kind of tell where other
people are i can't hear them at all so
there's i can never hear a person the
only people i ever hear the people who
call me on the phone twice a day
and people who knock at my door to
deliver me something um i can't hear
anyone in any rooms i did hear someone i
think maybe jumping today or like
working out
potentially but i can tell kind of where
other people are based on if they have
trash outside their doors because that's
how we get rid of
trash is just put them outside the door
so um that does give me
a vague idea of which rooms are occupied
um i think there's nobody next to me
there is someone across from me though
from what i can tell it's so weird it's
very strange does uber eats delivered to
your hotel yes i can get uber eats
um
i do have an editor yeah but he doesn't
edit everything
i'm not going crazy no i'm fine
i'm very busy so i'm completely okay
no problems for me at all um
i don't think this is going to bother me
as i keep trying to say
um can you get silver hair while in
quarantine i don't think i need to
i am getting my hair cut and colored as
soon as i get out though and i'm pretty
excited about it because i haven't done
that since 2019.
i already booked it because i'm looking
forward to it
um ubereats is pretty expensive probably
but i'm not needed it because i'm
getting food delivered so i'm okay
as in like the food the hotel's
delivering it's not a problem for me
um i don't want to stream resident evil
uh because i won't enjoy it as much i
said that on twitter
i'm recording it because when i stream i
pay less attention to the game because
i'm talking to people and it ruins games
for me a little bit so i try to not
stream
single-player games i like games too
much to want to stream everything
so i don't want to do it for resident
evil because i love resident evil
but i think that when i finish it i'll
probably play through it again and i
might stream my second playthrough
potentially are you going to play
biomutant yes
um i should have biomutant stuff up on
us
sunday i think or monday um but yes i
have biomutant
does playing vr help you escape being
locked in the room
i don't think playing vr is helping me
feel like i'm not in the room it's
certainly helping me work out
um which i love it's i do it twice a day
because i feel like it just gives you
like kind of a break from just sitting
on either this one chair or that chair
or the bed so there's not a lot of
options here
so i highly recommend using vr to anyone
who has to go through this kind of
experience because it's getting
moving in a way that like is engaging
um but i still know that i'm in a hotel
room because the space is so cramped
that i'm very conscious of what's around
me i actually haven't been able to play
one of the vr games that i spoke about
in
um the video that i made about working
out in vr oh shape
because it requires a little bit too
much lunging from side to side and i
keep failing because i keep hitting the
bed
so vr is a little bit limiting because
of the space
um so certainly [ __ ] aware that i'm
in a hotel room um
but it's definitely a great way to work
out i'm a huge fan
it's it's really wonderful i'm not going
to tell you
what i'm working on at santa monica
studio that's you don't get to ask that
beside visiting family what are you most
looking forward to doing in australia
it's always just food
i always want the sausage rolls and the
vanilla slices and the tim tams
otherwise because i don't have a dog and
naturally have been effectively locked
down in the u.s anyway
not a very different experience to this
overall really other than
my own apartment is my own apartment
which you know when you're in your own
space it feels a little bit different um
you have access to all of your own stuff
um and i had fresh air and then i could
open a window
um it's dogs though you know i didn't
get to see many dogs
and my mom has a dog and my sister has a
dog
so whenever i'm staying at my mom's
place i get to cuddle a labrador
and i'm very excited about living with
dogs again you miss them a lot
um this is someone who's grown up with
them my whole life so
is there really a guard outside your
hotel there is nobody outside my door
but you know when i checked in there
were australian police and australian
military
um the army and i think some air force
as well so
i imagine that they are still in the
lobby i imagine they're still here
uh so it is pretty well guarded yes i am
in a fortress am i playing on my xbox
that i couldn't on my pc
nothing so the reason to play on the
xbox uh is really just to be able to use
two separate things for different
purposes so when i record
i could be playing resident evil on pc
probably just fine but it's
much less stressful obviously on this
laptop that i can use obs
to record and then have something
running on the xbox it's like people who
have two pc streaming setups
um it's generally just more efficient
more reliable so any game that i have
access to right now by choice i will
play on xbox rather than on pc so that i
have the xbox running the game
the pc running gameplay or streams or
whatever else i'm doing
um and that's definitely uh i think i
will keep doing
though um i do have a ps5 waiting for me
also at my mom's house sent by
playstation australia so i can play
ratchet when it comes out
very excited about it
um yes the armed forces are here they
are
how's the air circulation in the room
terrible
terrible there's nothing nothing good
going on in here
one interesting thing is that it's
actually pretty cold outside but this
hotel room is really
warm so um
it's i was worried about that when i
first came i was worried that i'd be too
cold in the hotel
but i'm not at all it's it's warm in
here it makes it uh
a lot more comfortable my mom did send
me a bunch of warm socks because i asked
her for them because it was occasionally
like a little bit cold when i wake up
really early but otherwise i'm okay
um trying intentionally not to talk
about how long i'm in australia for
just in case it changes so not answering
that what's the best thing i've gotten
via room service well i'm not ordering
room service because we don't actually
have um
menus so it's not like you can call and
be like hey i want to order this thing
like a regular hotel room service you
just
get delivered meals so far i think i had
lasagna
and i love lasagna so that was probably
my favorite of them but um the pancakes
this morning were pretty good
and i've gotten a lot of fruit and i'm a
fan of fruit so
yeah uh there is air conditioner i'm
intentionally not turning it on because
it'll
make me even drier it'll make my ass
more worse so
all right with it being hot it's fine
uh yes it is uh
currently autumn in australia almost
it's almost winter
so yeah it's pretty chilly
may i ask does it smell not yet but i
imagine it will
i can't clean it um i'm eating food
you know and this just nothing you can
do uh like i said i drop some popcorn on
the floor and i'm like do i
like go into a dirty hotel room floor
and just pick out the bits of popcorn i
guess i do but i don't have gloves i
don't have a vacuum like i can't clean
this for two weeks which
yeah definitely a thing
do i have to pay for the preset meals no
they come as part of the two thousand
dollar charge
uh what am i streaming in quarantine tv
shows or movies welcome you must be new
here ninja face
neither i just play video games
sometimes so many q a's
yeah i don't really um watch movies or
tv
generally at all just play video games
um no they do not give you any cleaning
stuff
i am not allowed to crack a window it
doesn't even crack so no option there
do i have a nice view yeah it's all
right it's not
bad but uh i said this in the
last video i made about being in
quarantine that it's very
weird it doesn't seem real because i
can't go out there
and i'm very far from being able to go
out there so what i'm looking at just
seems fake
it may as well be um a video playing on
a loop
like and it's the same every day you
know it's
you're just seeing the same exact shot
of the world
every day it's [ __ ] weird
am i online shopping mall no not at all
have i played return there's a return on
gameplay on this video
sorry on this channel you should go
check that out uh would i go to this
hotel by choice
sure it's a nice hotel
i'm having a nice time um
[Music]
do i sing out loud to keep myself
company no because i think i mentioned
this i'm not a social person and i'm an
introvert so i don't do any like talking
to myself
type stuff i just don't need to
um i am also having i don't know if you
guys would be able to see it
i made a video about this uh in 2018 i
developed eczema
as a result of stress so now which i
almost see is a positive thing
anytime that i get extremely stressed my
skin peels see
my hands maybe you can't see that you
can see it on that one
that it's just my [ __ ] fingers like
more reddish that one too
so my skin's just fleeing my [ __ ]
body
in that hand it'll get worse um
and it's it's a convenient thing because
it means that i have a visual sign
of if i'm stressed where otherwise
sometimes i maybe won't realize that i'm
stressed but
i still think it's messed up that i was
so stressed in 2018 that i developed
something that will affect me for the
rest of my life
that's [ __ ] up um but i don't have
access to the medication for it because
it does require a prescription
so it can be a little bit painful and
i'm i'm not sure if the stress is
because i was so
busy the two weeks leading up to having
to fly here or
if it's being in here i'm not sure um
i don't know which thing i'm stressed
about like maybe it's happening now
because i'm in the hotel room but
my hands are just [ __ ] falling off
pretty much
it's uh it's a great time fun for
everyone but i'll be fine
why the filter um privacy so i don't
make my bed why do you need to see my
whole room man
uh well i continue to appear in funhouse
content like john yes and i do i never
stopped
we just recorded something on monday did
i finish near replicant no not yet i
intend to though
um seems like most of the questions now
are unrelated to the quarantine so
maybe i got through it all
uh magikop fx i probably will make a
video after the two weeks just maybe
even do a live stream like this i was
just trying to answer more questions
really
um tristan said do you think it would be
difficult to be back in a normal setting
without restrictions once you're out of
the hotel
so this is a thing that australians are
kind of wrong about in a way that's like
weird um no it won't be weird
uh because la from my
experience was pretty open anyway um
australians think that they're the only
country that's open at all and it's a
bit
odd uh but truthfully they have almost
no covet cases you know
so that is absolutely wonderful it's why
this lockdown is so strict if you get
covered in australia basically makes
national news
so i respect the hell out of it but no
it's not gonna be weird for me to walk
down the street because
americans were doing that anyway you
know with no masks
the whole time um even if on social
media it seemed like everyone was
wearing a mask and say like
maybe 20 of people were in la so
um sure things like nightclubs and music
vessels which are things that i don't
really do anyway
you couldn't do in the us uh restaurants
had some only outdoors situations
um but generally the answer is no this
isn't going to be very different from me
walking outside it'll probably be pretty
much the same
um yes i am vaccinated uh there are no
room service go to meals because we
don't have a say
um yes i will do let's plays on ratchet
and clank when i get it
um does this take away from my freedom i
don't feel like it does i'm completely
fine i chose to do this
if i didn't want to do it i wouldn't
have uh happy to be here
again not being able to breathe a bit of
a problem but um
it's part of why yeah australia did so
well and while
why while i was in la i didn't have to
worry about my grandma or my dad or
anyone i know who had has lung problems
or is high risk
um which i guess would also include my
stepdad at this point so
yeah i no i don't feel like my freedoms
are being infringed upon i am
i opted in you know i chose to i'm
totally fine
um
i think at this point
uh your australian ps5 play us versions
of games
it works on an account so you just play
whatever
account you have i i use my
australian uh playstation login on my
us playstation in any case
do i pay for my games of course i do
like virtually all of them i get some
games for free i got resident evil for
free but i didn't get return all the
pokemon snap
is a mix but yeah i pay for most games
um
would i reduce my quarantine time if i
could of course
i would love to and yeah plans for after
quarantina basically go say hi to my
family
but as far as i can tell most of the
questions we're getting now
are um ones that i've answered before
or unrelated from the looks of things
um so i think that that will be it for
me everyone
i just wanted to yeah talk about more of
the quarantine stuff people wanted to
ask about
what you all know that i'm doing okay
podcast obviously went up today
youtube's is obviously available for
purchase
today came out at 12 pacific time so 5am
for me
it's very cute um
you can get it link is in the
description please do let me know if you
get it i'm very excited
it uh it's a very cool thing to have as
someone who's such a big fan of toys in
general
so um thank you all for watching